[Music]
hello
when covid19 hit video calls suddenly
became the new normal i'm just trying to
control two streams at once in many jobs
including mine most meetings now take
place online
but what kind of effects could this
shift to virtual interactions be having
when the panic hit i had so many people
reaching out to me asking about like how
to run zoom studies and what's the
research out there now new research
shows that talking in person can be very
different to talking over a video call
at least when it comes to creativity we
were really interested when we saw the
results that simply being in the same
physical space as someone else
improves idea generation
every week i have an online catch up
with my manager noah where we discuss
possible upcoming film projects there's
this paper coming out which is about
creativity and particularly creativity
over
um like video calls obviously a lot of
my life has been spent on video calls
over the last two years so
data on video calls and creativity
definitely a film i'm interested in i
was hoping we could basically discuss
some ideas for
how the film is made coming up with
ideas and discussing them over video
call is exactly what melanie brooks set
out to study this work looks at um what
we are not calling the new normal which
is virtual interaction
and how that might affect innovation to
test this idea melanie set up an
experiment i've roped in my colleagues
nick and flora to demonstrate while
melanie explains participants would
either go into the same physical space
which was just an empty lab room or we
would split them into two separate lab
rooms and have them communicate with
video technology and we had them
generate ideas so our task now
is to generate creative uses for a
frisbee oh a frisbee
i mean the first one i think of straight
away because i've actually done this as
a plate of course frisbee plate the
study found that the in-person pairs
generated more ideas
there's around a 2.5 idea difference
so in-person groups are generating
around 16 or 17 ideas whereas the
virtual condition is generating between
13 and 15. but is this really that
surprising a lot of people mentioned
yeah zoom's just a worse version of
course people are just bad at zoom like
everything is going to be worse at zoom
so maybe this has nothing to do with
creativity
melanie tested this with a second task
and what we asked participants was to
identify their most creative idea
my favorite was definitely nick's bubble
wrap transport i i like the ant stopper
plate is the go to frisbee use yeah like
you've got guests over we've all been
there yeah plate i think plates is the
one the idea selection task uses very
different skills from the brainstorming
task but what's interesting is zoom
wasn't universally bad or video
conferencing wasn't universally bad when
it came to idea selection we found if
anything
the virtual condition was better so what
is it that might make idea generation
and only idea generation harder over a
video call we looked at how much
participants felt they connected with
the other through self-report we looked
at unconscious connection through
mimicry we looked at trust through a
monetary game
we also looked at whether there was
crosstalk where people were talking over
each other for communication
coordination
what we find is for the social
connection
no difference between conditions
for the communication coordination we
did find slight differences but it
couldn't explain the effect but there
was one difference between virtual and
in-person conversations that did seem to
make a difference and melanie spotted it
by tracking people's gaze
are you looking at your partner
are you looking at the surrounding
environment or are you looking at the
task
and it's interesting again if you ask
people what their intuition is they
think that there's more social
connection when we're in person and so
we probably engage with our partner more
but we found the exact opposite so we
found that in the virtual condition
people are looking
significantly more at their partner
almost double and because of that it's
at the expense of their broader
environment previous research has shown
that people are more creative when
they're less focused when i'm
communicating in person i have the
entire environment as our shared
environment wherever i look
that is going to be part of my partner's
environment too
however when we're talking virtually
our shared environment is pretty limited
to the screen
and we thought that this could lead to
more focus which should hurt idea
generation because we're actually the
most creative when we're unfocused and
free so rather than online conversations
being inherently always better or worse
it could be that we need to adjust how
we talk based on what we want to achieve
i use this now all the time i don't have
evidence for this yet but based on my
theory i always suggest turning off the
camera during idea generation so you can
walk around you can look around the idea
that virtual meetings could impact
things like focus and idea generation is
likely to be of great interest to people
around the world
but it's not as simple as saying right
let's get back to the office then it's
not like we have to be in person
it's not also that it doesn't matter
whether or not we're in person
creativity and innovation are important
in a lot of jobs including mine
but online meetings still offer some
advantages the ability to have meetings
more quickly uh potentially with more
people in different places of the world
i think could also be a massive benefit
so i could see some of those effects
potentially counseling out melanie is
keen to test her theories further but
there's a bit of a problem all of this
research has been halted because we
can't collect in-person data um without
people wearing masks and that of course
completely changes the experience so
there's tons of different experiments i
would love to run that i haven't been
able to do because we can't run
in-person studies right now
but for now melanie's work has certainly
given me something to consider when i'm
brainstorming ideas for my next film and
i have quite a lot of ideas
for this one i quite like the idea of
using this discussion of how to make the
story as the kind of backbone of the
story it is so nicely meta
this is gonna be an interesting one
amazing thanks now bye see you later bye
bye